[Music]
second nomination for crown your
beautiful wife was sitting there and we
what did you say to her yeah and I
wanted to be able to say more when we
got on stage so I'm a little sad what
did you want to say because they cut you
off and hold on they cut you off who
else do you want to thank thank them now
all right so let me let me thank Dan
Fogelman for bringing a show into the
world that tries to make it a little bit
better right instead of trying to make
America great again we're trying to make
it the best that it's ever been so thank
you Dan Fogelman for doing that my wife
you are unsung and everything that you
do for our family so it is my joy to
sing your praises
Ryan Michelle that they you are the bomb
and you gave me two of the most
beautiful human beings to ever grace
this planet Andrew Jason sterling Brown
Amar'e Michael Ryan Christian Brown your
daddy loves you I see you real soon
this one right here like this one right
here when I think about it
like Walter White held this joint tell
me what was going through your head as
you were turning around and looking at
everyone around you know people talk to
you and they say they voted for you and
they were pulling for you and there's a
good shot I get it feels like this is
historical it's been 19 years since a
brother brought from this particular
hard way Andre Braugher
Andre Braugher in 1998 and so to be the
next one I'm almost at a loss for words
Wow I move these two years in a row you
walk on one of these now I mean it's
like your party now this is what you do
man you know what after 15 years of
watching and being on the outside this
past two years have been like I'm an
infant fairyland or something you don't
say like I can still can't believe it
but I'm just happy that it's happening
and enjoying this moment right
[Music]
you